Hello Freak bitches,
but then over the course of the maybe three,
four or five years or so,
they started having real issues
and they don't necessarily tie that to the Diet because they remember feeling so
much better when they first switched to it,
so they don't think that what they're going,
what's happening three or four years later,
it could be the cause of their problems.
I see this all the time with vegetarian and Vegan diets.
That's exactly what I want to
talk to you about in terms of that because most people who switched to a
vegetarian or Vegan Diet,
you're going to see some instant benefits because of the fact that you have much
more nutrient dense foods.
You're eating a lot of vegetables,
you're you're,
you're changing your die in a lot of ways to the positive or towards a positive
away from what you were talking about,
those primary foods and Americans tend to eat all the processed sugar,
all the,
that just nonsense and chicken tenders and all that crap that people eat,
which is just so goddamn common,
right?
So automatically over that you're going to see some longterm benefits.
But one of the things that I've been reading is about people that have found
that over the longterm,
the lack,
this is contrary to what a lot of people think.
Yeah.
Lack of saturated fat and cholesterol,
dietary cholesterol and saturated fat leads to hormonal imbalances,
leads to your body having a harder time producing sex hormones and all these
different issues with your health or your body almost starts robbing itself to
make up for the nutritional deficiencies of your diet.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
uh,
we talked about this before,
but humans are animals and we're,
we're,
while we're omnivores and wait a minute,
I saw a video on youtube.
There's a guy that says there's no way that we are herbivores.
And then if we were so fucking wacky,
dude was saying,
if we,
if you're really a,
an,
uh,
an Omnivore,
you should be able to eat a squirrel.
Just grab it and eat it raw and like,
yeah,
no,
it's just the most bizarre.
There's some strange arguments out there.
It's like we shouldn't drink milk because you know,
there were the only,
uh,
you know,
we're the only animal in nature and in nature that drinks the milk of another
animal.
Yeah.
Well we're the only animal nature that uses iPhones too.
I have a whole bit about this.
It's hilarious you said that.
Yeah.
What else?
Appointing people do fly planes,
movies,
call each other on the phone and tell each other how awesome milk is.
It's a ridiculous argument.
But,
um,
so yeah,
getting back to,
to their ideological arguments more than scientific.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So it doesn't stand up to scrutiny,
but with,
with,
with a vegetarian or Vegan Diet.
So there's lots of different ways to look at this.
This starting with an evolutionary perspective,
which I was getting at.
Um,
omnivores are opportunistic.
They will eat whatever is available and they'll eat the most nutrient dense
foods that are available if they have a choice.
And that's just,
again,
that's survival.
You know,
an animal that is able to utilize the nutrients that are available in its
environment to maximum advantage is going to survive compared to one that
doesn't.
That's basic evolutionary theory.
So,
um,
if you study traditional peoples,
as far as I know,
still there's never been a traditional PE,
you know,
group that that has ever been identified that voluntarily followed a Vegan or
even vegetarian diet that I know of.
So that should tell you something right there.
And ironically,
the fact that you and I are even having this conversation,
this wouldn't even be happening if humans had not learned it's eaten meat
basically where there are a lot of anthropologists who now believe that eating
meat was essentially what made us human.
You know,
we came down out of the trees and we developed the development of tools that
could crack bones to give us access to the Merrill,
which is super nutrient dance or to sliced meat,
which allowed us to be able to digest the meat more quickly.
Um,
number one.
And then to the development of fire,
which allowed us to cook meat and cooking makes the nutrients in meat more
bioavailable,
allowed us to spend less time foraging for food.
So most large prime,
it's like gorillas or chimpanzees span over 80% of their day foraging for food
because most of the foods they eat are really not nutrient dense.
So they have to eat a boatload of stuff and just sit there and chew on the
plants all day to get enough nutrients.
And,
and so this evolutionary theory is that we learn to extract and harvest much
more nutrient dense foods from animals,
fats and and other nutrients and the meats and organ meats.
And we had,
we could then spend a lot less of our time going around getting food,
which allowed us and then develop bigger brains and you know,
become human and have this conversation where we're talking about a vegetarian
and Vegan diets.
Yeah,
it is kind of an interesting,
and it's also important to differentiate the difference between what you're
saying is essentially this science behind the development of the human animal,
right?
Versus the moral and ethical debates that lead and environmental debates,
which is also moral.
So we can,
we can,
we can talk about that too,
which is what influences people to become vegetarians and vegans,
which I totally respect.
I understand what they're saying.
The real problem is when they distort the reality of the scientific findings,
the human animal and diet.
And that's an issue with a lot of people that are vegetarians and vegans that go
on about how healthy they feel and how about how awesome,
but they're not doing blood lipid profiles.
And when they do,
like Sam Harris,
who is kind of the forum for ethical perspective,
for ethical reasons,
is tried a Vegan diet and his health is suffering.
He's getting real issues with his blood lipids.
Yeah.
What can someone do if they want to file that diet?
Like what,
what is imperative as far as healthy fats as far as getting,
making sure that your body doesn't have,
you're not taking in too many simple carbohydrates like,
hey,
what,
what steps need to be taking place?
And this is obviously not saying that you shouldn't fall Vegan Diet.
It shouldn't follow a vegetarian diet.
You should do whatever you want to do.
But there's gotta be some ways to mitigate some of the health consequences,
right?
Yeah,
there are.
And I believe that I agree with you that people should be free to make their own
choices.
I've never pushed a particular diet.
You know,
people sometimes ask me,
how do you convince someone to go Paleo?
I said,
I don't,
I don't spend my time doing that.
If someone wants my advice and ask me,
I'll give it to them,
but I'm not going around proselytizing for a particular way of eating.
Um,
so yeah,
let's break this down.
And we talked about the evolutionary argument for eating animal products and
there's a scientific argument,
which now is what we're talking about the issue with.
And we should,
we should even kind of distinguish between vegetarian and Vegan diets cause
they're,
they're actually quite different.
And I think it is possible for some people to be healthy with a vegetarian diet.
I think it's a lot less likely with the Vegan Diet.
And I guess I would say it this way.
Um,
if you have,
if you're Vegan and you're eating a Vegan Diet,
you need to have a perfect vegan diet to be healthy and you need to know what
you're doing in terms of supplementation and how to meet the nutrient needs that
aren't being met through diet.
And at least in my experience,
there are very few that actually do it right.
Um,
when it's done right,
I think it's possible for some people to be,
to,
to be healthy and thrive.
And that's obvious because there are people like rich roll who's like out there.
He's a Vegan triathlete who's out there doing centuries and killing it,
ultra marathon.
He is just an amazing athlete and he's Vegan.
And so,
you know,
you can't say that it's not working for it and you can try to say that you're
going help.
So it looks like he's 30 years older than me.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a great guy.
I've met him a couple of times.
Um,
and uh,
so it certainly,
it works for some people,
but there are a lot of factors that determine whether it's going to work.
So one is how well you do it too is you know,
whether you know what you're dealing with,
supplementation in terms of getting the necessary nutrients.
Three is genetics.
So let me,
there are genetic differences that determine how well we convert precursor
nutrients into the nutrients that we actually need.
And let me give three examples to make this more real.
So one is EPA and Dha.
These are these long chain of mega three fats that we've heard so much about
that are crucial for brain function,
cardiovascular function,
et cetera.
And we primarily,
you get them by eating fish.
There are no sources of those in a plant based diet except for algae.
Um,
but an algae is not the bioavailable.
And how many people do know that eat algae?
I don't know.
I mean we can,
you can cause that famous green supplementation stuff is,
you can use it as a supplement but very few people are eating it.
So,
um,
but you,
but there is something called Alpha linolenic acid,
which is in walnuts and flax seed.
That's an a mega three plant fat and,
and humans in theory can convert some of that plant based Omega Three into this
long chain EPA and Dha that we need.
But the thing,
here's the thing,
only about five to 10% of that gets converted into EPA and even less to Dha,
like two to 5%.
So you have to be chugging tablespoons of flax oil in order to get as much EPA
or Dha Epa that you would get from eating just a little bit of fish.
And that's if everything is going well,
because if you have deficiency of any nutrients that are involved in the
enzymatic conversion of those plant based fats into the long chain fats,
then you won't make those conversions at that optimal rate.
It'll be even less.
And ironically,
many of those nutrients are nutrients that are not well represented in a Vegan
or vegetarian diet.
So that's one example.
Another would be vitamin K two,
which is uh,
uh,
a different form of vitamin K that's recently been discovered.
And it's really important for cardiovascular and bone health.
It basically puts,
make sure that calcium gets in our bones and our teeth and our heart tissues
where it belongs and keeps it out of the soft tissues like our arteries where
calcium would make our arteries hard and increased the risk of a heart attack.
So,
um,
k two is only really in animal foods with the exception of some fermented foods
like Natto,
which is a Japanese fermented soybean product that most people cannot stand.
Um,
it's,
it's a strong taste.
Not very many people are eating it here.
Uh,
Kufier and,
and Sauerkraut and Kimchi have,
have k,
k two in it.
Kaffir I've been saying Kiefer my whole life,
that's how I've never heard it.
So that's how they say it,
where [inaudible] is from.
Every other person I've ever met says Kiefer,
so don't worry about it.
Okay.
And could fear from Nolan fear you'll be in the select few,
but no,
honestly I feel good about it already.
So yes,
you can feel superior.
Now,
can I stop you real quick just because we're going to,
I want to get a little bit,
um,
uh,
onto this track of what you were describing.
Boats,
fish oil and conversion and the difference between flax seed oil.
What,
what can vegans take in order to sort of recommend that vegans take micro algae
because it has preformed Dha in it.
So you bypass that whole conversion issue and if they do take micro algae,
is that sufficient or how much different is that than eating fish?
Well,
it's quite different because fish have a lot of other nutrients aside from EPA
and Dha.
They routine,
they have selenium,
they have a lot of other bioavailable nutrients.
But,
but,
and the other disadvantage is you have to take a boat load of,
of LG boatload.
Give me a,
uh,
I think so.
There are different products have different amounts,
but um,
you know,
I think you'd have to take six to nine cups a capsules a day of the average
algae supplement in order to meet your Dha.
No.
Done.
It could,
it's absolutely possible,
but that would be a good way to be healthy with the Vegan Diet.
That would be one way to address the shortcoming of know of lack of Dha on the
Vegan Diet.
There are other shortcomings,
other nutrients like B 12 which that's a big issue and vegans need to be
supplementing with that.
There's a myth out there that there are some plant sources of B 12 like seaweed
and in spirit like spirulina and nutritional yeast,
but those actually contain,
uh,
kind of phony forms of B 12 that that can block the absorption of true 12,
which is only found in animal products or supplements.
So a B 12 supplement would be really important.
That's why it's the source of a B 12 supplement.
Um,
they,
it's synthetic,
it's synthetic I think,
but they just,
there's three forms.
It'd be 12.
There's,
there's hydroxy Kabbalah,
man and Methylcobalamin or f or four forms that you can supplement with
Cyanocobalamin and Adenosylcobalamin and Cyanocobalamin is the synthetic form.
And then the other ones are natural forms of B 12 that you would encounter in
food.
So people can supplement with any of those.
The,
the natural forms are better to supplement with cause they're more bioavailable.
But definitely if a Vegan,
I would recommend supplementing with B 12 because there aren't any sources of it
in the Diet.
And studies have shown that 68% of vegetarians are deficient in B 1280 3% of
vegans are versus just 5% of omnivores.
Wow.
So it's a big difference.
We're not,
you know,
and that's a factor in,
in many different issues,
right?
It's a factor in the production of muscle.
Uh,
all production of all red blood cells depends on B12 and full eight and so on.
I mean that's pretty fundamental,
right?
And then the Myelin Sheath requires be 12 and this is why B 12 deficiency can
mimic the,
the signs of Parkinson's or Alzheimer's to these and people who are aging.
B 12 deficiency happens in elderly people,
not because they're on a vegan diet because they have low stomach acid and they
don't absorb the B 12 as well as we do when we're younger.
And so a lot of people who are elderly who have no symptoms of Parkinson's or
Alzheimer's,
they can sometimes be misdiagnosed with these conditions when they're actually
just be 12 deficient.
So it's a series.
It's a real,
really important nutrient.
How can vegans be assured that the B12 that they're buying does not have a
animal products?
Uh,
we do.
Do they have B12 when you bind a supplement that typically it's usually a,
I'm not the best person to ask about that because I'm,
I'm not a Vegan myself.
I was a macrobiotic at one point.
What does that mean?
What's the difference?
That's deep,
deep
macrame macrobiotics is that is a whole nother system of way of looking at
foods,
a job and you know,
uh,
Japanese,
approach and um,
you know,
the whole reason I came to do what I'm doing now.
So I got really,
really sick and my twenties I almost died and I spent about 10 years just trying
to get back to health.
What did you pick from?
I was in Indonesia.
I mentioned earlier,
I'd traveled around the world and I was surfing and I got the classic tropical
illness.
It's like immediate dysentery,
Giardia and blastocystis hominis so to parasites and an Amoeba and was just,
you know,
coming out of both ends,
delirious,
didn't remember really anything for three days.
Um,
luckily there was one other Australian guy in the village that I was in who had
some antibiotics in his medical kit that kind of brought me back from the brink,
but,
um,
between the parasites and then the multiple rounds of antibiotics I had to take
to get rid of the parasites after that,
it just wreaked havoc on my gut and it took me basically 10 years to recover my
Ho yeah,
10 years.
It was like the last decade when I was at 10 years because you approached it in
correctly and you could do it better now or was it just such a devastating round
of disease that I think a little of both.
I mean,
so I was,
I'm 42 now and I was 25 when this first happened and we didn't know anything
about the gut and the microbiome compared to what we know now.
There was very little awareness on this topic,
that point.
Yeah.
Just in 15 years,
it's just,
or 20 years.
It's,
it's crazy.
So,
you know,
I took way more antibiotics than I would have done in retrospect because that's
what the doctors were prescribing and saying,
look,
you've got these parasites,
we've got to get rid of them.
This is how you do it.
And you know,
and I think the antibiotics,
if it could have been like the treatment was probably worse than the disease for
me,
you know,
after the number of courses of antibiotics that I took.
Wow.
So along that path I tried to out every special diet you can possibly imagine
including becoming a vegetarian and a Vegan and then a macrobiotic,
Vegan and raw food vegan.
I've been there,
done that.
And um,
so I'm completely sympathetic like to all,
and I'm also a longtime meditater and Buddhist.
So I understand the ethical argument very well.
Many of my friends don't eat meat.
I'm sympathetic and I care about the environment.
I'm sympathetic to that argument.
I'm certainly not,
you know,
I'm coming to this from a place of I think a pretty balanced viewpoint.
Um,
and uh,
the,
the issues for me,
the reason why I eventually brought animal products back into my diet with the
Aye,
Aye.
It became clear that I needed to do that for my own health and I was able to
reach a level of
understanding and,
uh,
about the moral,
ethical and environmental choices that I was making.
Um,
that,
that I felt good about.
I want to go back to something you were saying about the,
you know,
vegans and vegetarians and how to kind of optimize if you're doing that diet.
So,
um,
two things that wanted to address.
One was you asked about mollusks.
I've actually argued that a vegetarian diet with shellfish and organ meats would
be better than a Paleo Diet with no shellfish and organ meats.
Interesting.
And that's because of what we talked about earlier.
Muscle meats,
organ meats and shellfish are the two most nutrient dance classes of foods.
Like I,
I've just been finishing the curriculum from my clinician training program where
I'm,
um,
you know,
going through systematically every nutrient and I'm looking at,
uh,
in nutrition data what the most,
the highest food sources of those nutrients are.
And again,
I wish I had the thing to just lay it out and show you.
But you know,
in almost every case it's an organ meat or a shellfish that's the highest source
of that,
whether you're talking about be 12 or iron or copper or zinc or full eight.
It's always beef,
liver,
chicken,
clams,
oysters,
et cetera.
And so if someone was a veggie vegetarian who's willing to fudge a little bit
and eat just organ meats and shellfish,
they,
I think that would be a healthier approach than someone who's just eating lean
muscle meat.
Um,
organs get tossed out a lot.
It's a,
it's really,
it's a real problem in the hunting world where,
um,
when people got an animal,
they leave the gut pile.
And there's even a gutless method that a lot of people use when the,
uh,
they take on a big game animal,
like an elk or something like that.
They just,
they leave it behind.
They leave the heart,
they leave the liver.
But I saw this documentary on wolves and was really fascinating was one of the
ways that they distinguish who the alpha is.
And then wolf pack is the Alpha Wolf is the one who eats the liver,
the liver and the fascinating.
There are other animals that that's true.
And I think that was true in a hunter gather societies as well.
And someone was trying to say to me,
well,
we'll livers process toxins.
Don't you think they'd be filled with toxins?
That's a common
misconception.
The liver processes then,
but this,
the fat stores them.
So if you're concerned about toxins in food,
you should make sure that you're eating pasture raised organic fats like butter
and cream and things.
If you eat dairy products,
animal fats,
grass fed,
grass fed butter,
uh,
if you eat lard or tallow or anything like that,
it should come from pasture raised animals because the fat is where toxins are
stored,
the liver processes then um,
so when you're,
I'm sorry to interrupt you boat.
So when you're eating anything that comes from an animal that's been fed grain,
you're dealing with an animal that has the same sort of inflammation issues a
person has
from processing things that it's not naturally supposed to process like pat
processed wheat and the bleached flour and things besides antibiotic residue.
Right?
Yeah.
So when you're taking in those animal products that we traditionally do,
whether it's butter or milk or dairy or cheese or things along those lines,
when you're taking those from an animal that's eating grain,
you are actually getting the fats.
So your,
your,
it's less healthy than actually eating the liver of that animal.
Yeah,
I would,
it may be.
I mean the liver is more nutrient dense anyways,
but um,
pasture is animal fats,
uh,
have a lot more nutrients than conventionally raised fats because the animals
are eating grass and grasses way more nutrient dense than the grains that you
know,
conventional animals are fed.
Also the Omega threes and sixes are different.
The ratio,
the May mega six is the same but Omega three is three or four times higher in
pasture raised animals.
Why does that make it six to sign?
It's a good question.
It used to be,
you know,
the,
the kind of a consensus was that Omega sixes would be higher in Omega threes it
would be lower,
but actually it looks like and make a six is constant and Omega three is higher.
The Omega three is higher because of the grass probably has more alpha linolenic
acid,
which is the plant based form that day.
Then animal does a conversion.
I mean that's the thing that's really interesting to consider here too is humans
are really inefficient and making these conversions of these less active
nutrients to the more active ones.
We started talking about it with EPA and Dha,
k k vitamin K one is what's converted into k.
Two cows are experts at doing that.
They're really good at it.
Humans not so much.
So when we eat the animal and the animal is basically done the work for us and
we get the preformed final nutrient that we need rather than having to do those
steps ourselves.
And this is starting to rub,
it's just,
it's just a function of the adaptation of people developing while eating these
animals.
I think so,
yeah.
Beta carotenes and other example that's a precursor to active vitamin A or
retinol and Beta carotenes have some benefits in our bodies,
but retinols is the real thing.
You know what?
We need more than anything.
And uh,
that conversion is as low as three to 5% and some people,
and in fact there,
there are some who don't make the conversion at all.
And those are the people who turn orange after a carrot juice fast.
Ever seen anyone with like the orange palms?
It happens.
My friend Andy used to drink so much carrot juice that the inside of his hands
and his skin would turn orange.
Yeah.
So he probably wasn't good at converting Beta carotene into retinol because we
should be able to do that,
but some people can't.
But it isn't just the mass quantity.
So yeah,
I mean it could be that too.
But um,
uh,
the retinol is only really present in organ meats and pasture raised fats.
It's not even really in muscle meats like lean ground beef or chicken breast,
boneless chicken breasts or,
um,
so in order to get retina,
we need to consume these pasture raise fats or we need to consume Oregon means.
And as you pointed out,
the organ meats have really fallen out of favor in the US.
And this is only recent,
like I bet you our grandparents ate a lot more organ meats then we eat still in
some,
you know,
many parts of the world.
They still eat organ meats.
More try.
We do.
Yeah.
Liver and onions is a very famous dish.
Beef heart.
And so you'll see within the Paleo primal kind of world that organ meats are
making a comeback because we understand now what the nutrient density of these
foods is and there's less now,
even in the mainstream world,
there's less of a solid argument that can be made about these having cholesterol
or you know,
high levels of saturated fat.
They would prevent us from meeting them.
Now,
what would be the difference in terms of the nutritional density of molluscs
versus Oregon meat?
So like if you were trying to,
if you had a vegetarian or a Vegan is on the fence and you know,
you made these arguments that are very rational and logical and he said,
look,
mollusks are essentially a very,
very primitive form of life that doesn't feel pain.
And you could argue that there's more evidence that some plants feel pain and
plants also have some very intense level of communication.
Where there,
there,
there's a really interesting,
uh,
addition of radio lab recently where they went into this,
where they sort of are trying to understand the difference between,
uh,
the,
not the difference rather,
but the,
the,
the complicated relationship between these different plants and the mycelium and
the soil and all of the different fungus in the soil that also acts as sort of a
transportation method for various nutrients and minerals.
And they're actually pulling these minerals out of the rock and they're getting
sugars from the plants and they're exchanging them for minerals.
And that there's this really complex interaction that we have sort of just
looked at and said,
oh,
there's dirt and there's plants.
But there's a lot going on between these various life forms and one of them
being fungus,
which again is closer to an animal that it is still plant but is imperative for
the life of these plants.
And then somehow or another,
there were actually even sharing resources where if they find,
or they're allotting resources to certain plants that are more deficient or
they're trying to channel resources to them.
So there's some form of communication.
And exchange here.
Yeah,
that's,
that's intelligence right there.
I mean,
Paul Stamets has done amazing work on,
um,
my youngest,
youngest in general.
Um,
yeah,
I would say that that's a really good option.
I mean,
um,
when you look at nutrients like specific nutrients that it goes back and forth
between liver and,
you know,
Oregon meats and shellfish and some,
some nutrients,
uh,
organ meats are higher,
like vitamin A or iron and other nutrients.
Shellfish are generally higher like with zinc or copper.
Um,
but certainly even,
even,
uh,
shellfish are higher in almost all of the key nutrients that we need.
Then a lot of the plant based food alternatives that they would be choosing
from.
And so if this a Vegan was willing to eat molluscs I would say that that would
be a great idea.
And,
and uh,
the,
the benefit there is you don't need to eat a lot like three ounces a single
serving,
uh,
can meet your copper requirement for the entire week.
Oh Wow.
Just one time.
All the time.
Oysters.
And same with iron.
I think if I'm going off the top of my head,
I'll iron and zinc,
it can nearly meet your entire weekly requirement.
So it's not like you have to eat a ton of these things.
You,
you know,
you have a serving of clams once a week and you have a serving of oysters once a
week,
uh,
you know,
on top of,
uh,
getting as much nutrient density as you can,
um,
that should do,
that's be 12.
That's iron,
that sink,
that's copper,
EPA and Dha.
The launching and Omega three fats are in these,
uh,
in these malls cause as well.
Uh,
and it,
they're typically low on the toxicity,
uh,
scale too.
They're not,
they don't tend to have a lot of mercury.
They don't bio accumulate a lot of toxins compared to some other,
you know,
Predator species of fish that are higher in the food chain that accumulated a
lot of toxins.
Is there any benefit to eating them cooked versus raw one way or the other?
Well,
you know,
there's all,
there is the chance of disease and you know,
eating raw wasters.
Um,
I think it's pretty minimal compared to some other risks,
but it's,
it is there.
And cooking,
yeah.
Mitigates that.
Definitely.
I think in general,
cooking makes the nutrients in meat and animal products more bioavailable rather
than last.
Uh,
and that's,
and,
and vegetables,
it's,
it depends on the vegetable and the,
um,
and the method of cooking.
But,
uh,
it,
it's a mix.
It's more of a mixed bag,
but with [inaudible] me to genuinely improve the bioavailability.
So it really is in a lot of ways an ideological issue where it's sort of framed
that,
you know,
you don't want to contribute to suffering,
but these things really don't suffer there.
Yeah.
But even there,
you know,
as we talked about,
you're going to contribute to contribute to suffering and potentially more if
you're looking on the scale of individual lives.
And it might sound like this is nit picky,
but it's not.
We're talking about actual lives,
you know,
and,
and then you have to start evaluating like,
is a cow more ascension are worth,
you know,
the life of a cow worth more than the life of a rabbit or a vole or the kinds of
animals that are being killed.
And in the end,
you know,
in the production of these plant foods is,
it's a real question.